hi this is presh talwalkar can you solve
this math problem which has gone viral
this problem was asked to
eight-year-olds in vietnam
place the numbers one through nine using
each number exactly once to make a valid
equation
the numbers should be written in the
empty boxes and the expression should be
read from left to right
wrapping around the corners
the boxes which contain the semicolons
are the same thing as the mathematical
operation of division
can you figure this out you need to put
the numbers 1 through 9 so that the
entire expression equals 66.
this is not an easy problem and you
should give it a try before watching the
video i'm going to explain how you can
come up with the solution
let's think about this problem logically
when we want to work out a solution we
should first make the step of writing
the expression in the normal way we
write mathematical expressions
as a single line from left to right
this will make it easier to put in the
numbers
the next thing we want to think about is
how easy it would be to guess a solution
how many ways are there to put the
numbers 1 through 9 in these 9 boxes
well we can put 9 different numbers in
the first box so there are nine
possibilities for the first number that
we can put in
once we do that
there are eight possibilities we can put
in the second box these are any of the
eight numbers we haven't put in the
first box
the third box will only have seven
possibilities because we've used two
possibilities for the first two boxes
continuing the logic
we would have one less possibility for
each box until we get to the last box
which will be forced by the numbers we
picked in the previous boxes
in total there are 9 factorial
or
362
880 possibilities
that's a lot of possibilities to try and
work through it just by brute force
and therefore we're not going to figure
out a solution just by simply guessing
and checking every single possibility
so let's work out the solution logically
i'm first going to remove these boxes
and then i'm going to put parentheses
because we need to respect the order of
operations
anytime there's a multiplication or
division that needs to be evaluated
before we do the corresponding addition
to the left or the right
so now i was thinking this is how i came
up with the solution i thought well this
problem was asked to eight-year-olds so
maybe there's a really easy solution
so what if i just wrote the numbers one
through nine in order from left to right
this actually got pretty close to the
answer of 66 this got to about 53.
i thought well
what if i wrote the numbers in
descending order so i wrote them from 9
to 1.
quite surprisingly i again got pretty
close to the answer
so from here i thought maybe i can
modify this expression to get to a
result of 66.
so i experimented a little bit and what
came to my mind was i thought about this
eight seven and this four
i thought maybe i could have eight
divided by four and i would switch the
seven out but that didn't really work so
then i thought maybe i could switch the
three numbers what if i have
just move these three numbers one over
to the right in a circle so i would have
four and then eight and then seven
well if i was dividing four by eight
then i would need to make one more
adjustment let's move these three
numbers around so i would have one times
three divided by two
when i did that i got to an answer of
55.
the good thing is this is a whole number
and the second good thing is that it's
only 11 less than our answer that we
want of 66
and then i looked at the expression i
said oh this is easy if i switch the six
and the five i'm going to increase
the product 12 by 5 going to 12 by 6 i'm
going to increase this by 12 and then
when i replace the six by the five i'm
going to reduce it by one so that's
exactly going to increase the entire
expression by 11. and that gets us to
our answer of 66
so here is one solution
to our problem
in fact after i wrote out this solution
i realized
one more thing there are in fact
multiple solutions that we can get once
we figure out one answer
how is this
well notice that we can switch the
numbers
that are being added
and it will have it will generate
another solution
we'll still get the same answer 66 but
we just put the two numbers in different
positions
similarly
we can switch the two numbers which are
being multiplied
that won't have any effect on our final
expression so that'll give us another
possible answer when we write the
numbers in the grid
of course once we do that we can switch
the two numbers which are being added
so anytime you come up with an answer
you can actually generate a total of
four answers
by placing the numbers in different
positions because certain operations are
commutative that is it doesn't matter
which way you evaluate them addition and
multiplication are commutative
but these aren't the only answers
i looked online and some people had
posted other ways that you could get to
66
and these are completely different
arrangements of numbers and each time
you have these remember you can generate
other solutions by swapping the two
numbers which are being added or
swapping the two numbers which are being
multiplied
so how many solutions are there in total
i don't know if you come up with an
answer please leave a comment or if you
just come up with other solutions it'd
be very interesting to see what the
solutions are
somewhere i read the answer is a hundred
and twenty and this seems to make sense
because it should be a multiple of four
if someone said there are say a hundred
and one answers that wouldn't really
make sense because any time we generate
one answer we know that they come in
sets of four
so i think there are 120 solutions
but i don't know exactly so if you
figure it out please provide a link
leave a comment and let us know what you
come up with
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can also catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
written several books about math puzzles
and interesting topics just like the one
in this video you can also check out my
book about game theory
thanks for watching